[Music]
chris hemsworth knows how to kick back
and relax luckiest girl in the world the
34 year old star was snapped hanging out
on the beach in his native Australia
over the weekend enjoying a few beers
with his close pal Matt Damon and his
wife Elsa Pataky the dad of three was
also snapped kissing his leading lady
who put her killer physique on display
in a black bikini she's pretty strong 41
year old actress instagrammed a few pics
from the getaway and their time at a
local Blues Fest including this shot
with Damon and his wife Luciana Barroso
she captioned the photo quote fun times
with my favorite people and on Monday
Damon and his wife of 12 years were
spotted in Byron Bay also packing on the
PDA Damon and Hemsworth have gotten
super close over the years and in
January Pataki told et about her close
friendship with Barroso we have a really
good relationship she's Argentinian so I
think like this fan is just like total
connectors in a way and their matching
tattoos just three points for it just
simple let's say today tomorrow and
forever
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]